en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
emergencia que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde
nuestros hogares para llevarles toda la
información -soy valentina torres
sánchez gracias por acompañarme
iniciamos en eeuu porque el contagio del
presidente de donald trump le dio una
gran visibilidad al llamado cóctel de
anticuerpos con el que fue tratado en
principio el mandatario estamos hablando
de un medicamento desarrollado por la
farmacéutica roche general que ha sido
considerado por expertos como uno de los
más prometedores para tratar la
enfermedad previa suministrárselo al
jefe de estado la compañía había
publicado los resultados de sus más
recientes pruebas clínicas
lo que pudimos mostrar previamente esta
semana fue que los pacientes que más lo
necesitaban los pacientes que tenían los
niveles más altos del virus en su cuerpo
y que su respuesta inmune estaba siendo
pobre
y fue que haydn
oren al darles nuestro cóctel de
anticuerpos para aumentar o subsistir su
respuesta inmune pudieron eliminar el
virus más rápidamente
breitbart ers esencialmente el fármaco
contiene los llamados anticuerpos
monoclonales copias fabricadas de los
anticuerpos reales producidos por el ser
humano es un medicamento que no ha
recibido la aprobación de la
administración de drogas y alimentos por
lo que sigue siendo experimental es
importante recordar que en este momento
no hay tratamientos que hayan sido
aprobados que se haya aprobado que son
efectivos para prevenir o disminuir la
enfermedad en esta etapa cuando no hay o
hay pocos síntomas así que todo es
experimental todo está siendo analizado
el tratamiento se suministra con una
única dosis vía intravenosa de una hora
de duración y los estudios que se llevan
a cabo actualmente se encuentran en
etapa 3 uno de ellos es para prevenir
una posible infección y el otro para
tratar la enfermedad cuando una persona
ya se ha contagiado
dejamos el kobe y ahora hablamos de los
noveles científicos el instituto
karolinska que entrega el galardón de
medicina anunció que los ganadores de
este año fueron el británico michael of
tom y los estadounidenses
harvey y alter y charles wright los tres
son pioneros en la detección del virus
que causa la hepatitis
fitch realmente es un descubrimiento que
salva vidas y es clave ir al principio
para entender lo básico los
descubrimientos originales y lo que han
permitido
francés ha habido muchos avances en
terapias pero todo eso ha sido posible
por el descubrimiento inicial de este
virus recordemos que la hepatitis a es
la inflamación del hígado para el final
de la década de los 70 harvey walter y
sus colegas mostraron que a pesar de los
análisis de sangre que descartaban
infección por hepatitis a y b había
pacientes que continuaban con
inflamación en el hígado tras recibir
una transfusión sanguínea en 1989 maikel
horton aisló la secuencia genética del
virus y fue bautizado hepatitis c
posteriormente charles en bryce mostró
la prueba definitiva de que el virus
provocado hepatitis continuamos con el
nobel de física fue otorgado al
británico roger penrose el alemán
reinhard genzel y la estadounidense
andre agassi la cuarta mujer en la
historia en ganar este premio en física
todo ello por sus descubrimientos
relacionados con agujeros negros perros
fue el primero en demostrar
matemáticamente que los agujeros negros
existen cuando una estrella muere
explota hacia adentro y hacia fuera si
la estrella tiene suficiente masa luz
hombros se comprimen y forman un punto
de densidad infinita que atrae todo lo
que se cruce en su horizonte es decir un
agujero negro por su parte ken selig es
descubrieron el agujero negro
supermasivo sagitario a que es el
responsable de arrastrar estrellas hacia
él con gran velocidad debido a la fuerza
de gravedad que contiene
realmente hemos demostrado más allá de
cualquier duda que existen los objetos
que eran parte de la teoría de einstein
los llamados agujeros negros
en forma de objetos supermasivos
formados en el proceso de evolución y
crecimiento de las galaxias
por último tenemos el nobel de química
entregado a la francesa manuel jacques
pendía y al estadounidense jennifer duna
ambas genetistas investigadoras reciben
el galardón por desarrollar una técnica
de edición del genoma que funciona como
una especie de tijeras moleculares que
permiten localizar y cortar cualquier
secuencia del código genético en un
animal planta
o microbio la academia de las ciencias
de estocolmo indicó que esta tecnología
ha sido revolucionaria al contribuir al
desarrollo de nuevas terapias contra el
cáncer al mismo tiempo que puede ser la
clave para curar muchas enfermedades
hereditarias de origen genético
champions decid haft-e tir where you go
la capacidad de cortar el adn donde
usted desee ha revolucionado las
ciencias de la vida ahora podemos editar
genomas fácilmente como deseemos son
algo que antes era difícil incluso
imposible
hoy en día respecto senna es una
herramienta común entre los laboratorios
de bioquímica y biología molecular
también se utiliza en el
fitomejoramiento y para nuevos
tratamientos de enfermedades humanas las
tijeras genéticas se descubrieron hace
apenas ocho años pero ya han beneficiado
enormemente a la humanidad concluimos
este espacio en italia donde se llevó a
cabo el salón naútico de génova allí fue
presentado el primer barco impreso en
3-d se llama mambo mide 6,5 metros de
largo por 2.5 metros de ancho tiene un
peso de aproximadamente 800 kilos y está
equipado con un sistema de navegación
real así llegamos al final de esta
crónica cuídense si es posible que
deseen casa gracias por su compañía y
continúen con más en france 24 y
france24 puntocom
sí